升息一開始,股市反而開始上漲,
因為我們說短期最大利空出盡了,
也就是在年底前有機會再次改寫新高點,
甚至就挑戰五萬點。
大家好,歡迎再次收看投資的一千營業,
我是豐哥。
升息循環開始了,
但最後會升到哪裡,
這是現在大家最關注的事。
而且對臺股的影響又是什麼?
我們今天來討論一下。
那我們先從上週的關鍵場景說起,
上週三,就是9月6號的那一天,
年總會議12比0 全票通過升息一碼
就是0.25個百分點
那聯邦基金利率呢
代表短期利率的水準
就來到3.75%到4%這個區間
那這個利率水準是
2023年7月以來
整整三年多第一次升息到這個水準
所以市場在升息前呢
其實已經嚇了一跳
因為本來是預期不升息的
但後來就開始慢慢對市場升息的機率越來越高
本來是六成
後來到八成甚至最後到了九成
所以市場在這個預期升高的情況下
十年期美債的殖利率也是一路就往上衝
先衝到了5%
後來又到了5.010%
這是19年來的新高
臺灣的央行的禮監事會議
也做了這個利率決策會議
但是他們的決定是不跟
重貼限率就維持在2%不變
那我們來看一下臺股在這個事件後是怎麼樣呢
臺股在9月18號當天呢
大漲了892點
收在47,180點
那外資單日買超近870億元
可以說是最近以來非常大的一次買超
所以大家的解讀是利空出盡
但是真的利空出盡了嗎
還是它只是一個短期的興奮
所以我們今天要回答三個問題
美國利率這一波會升到哪裡
那轉折點
也就是說高原期之後的轉折向上的時間點
會大概在什麼時候
另外這一波的升息對股市跟債市會有什麼影響
最後我們還加上一點
大家很多人就忽略掉的變數
就是這一次葉門胡塞武裝的攻擊
是不是會產生一些意外的結果
首先我們來看利率的未來趨勢
那麼利率會升到哪裡呢
我們要先看點證圖
這是我們來看美國利率最重要的一個參考數據
聯總會這次公佈了新的點證圖
就是每位參與決策官員對
未來利率的預測
那我整理如下
我們先來看
目前呢
在 FED 的點證圖的中位數呢
大概是在 3.875%
那對應到利率的實際的這個
政策指導區間呢
就是3.75%到4%這個區間
就是現在FED設定的利率水準
那預計到2026年底呢
中位數會達到4.1%
也就是對應4%到4.25這個區間
那麼2027年底呢
也是4.1%
所以同樣是4%到4.25這個區間
值得注意的是
2028年底的這個中位數呢
是來到了3.9%
對應3.75%到4%這個區間
也就是從2027年底到2028年底
這一個一年的時間裡面呢
利率是看向下的
那我們可以看前面呢
是從這個3.75%到4%呢
在這個區間呢
甚至呢是不是有可能在往上
再升一碼都有機會的
可是到了2027年底
接到2028年之後呢
反而是有走向降息的趨勢
那4.1%代表什麼呢
代表到年底前還要再升一碼
也就是升到4%到4.25%
那18位官員有16位認為今年會升
因為今年剩下兩次的會議
其中4位甚至可能認為會升兩次
不過這是比較激進的主張
那主席怎麼看呢
就主席自己本身沒有交點陣圖
因為他不要讓大家知道他心裡的自己的想法
不過他在記者會上呢
有把這一次的升息形容成
我們移除了一部分貨幣政策的寬鬆
欸這個說法就是很巧妙
因為呢
他說的是移除了寬鬆
所以他不覺得現在的利率已經很緊
他只是移除了一部分寬鬆
所以這代表後面還有一些空間
那市場怎麼看
目前期貨市場的預估呢
就10月28號的那一次再升一碼的幾率
現在大概是5成多
那到12月的會議之前的這個升息
就是9成
就是因為兩次會議
就這兩次會議裡面
如果要再升一碼的幾率
就大概9成
不過大家不要一聽到升息循環
開始很緊張
因為為什麼
我們上一次的升息循環
是2022年那一次
那一次大家都形容是暴力升息
因為從2022年到2023年
一共升息了11次
雷吉爾夫夫真的很嚇人
達到525個基點
就是5.25個百分點
把利率從0%一口氣
就升到了5.25%到5.50%這個區間
所以那一次造成嚴重的股債雙殺
如果那段時間就開始投資人
應該印象很深刻
再一次就尤其是產業
不過這一次我們來根據目前點證圖判斷
整個升息應該就是兩次
最多最多就三次
那每次只會升一碼
所以升息的高點應該不會超過
4.25%到4.50%
可是就會在高點停留蠻長一段時間
升的不多
但等他要降下來的時間會等很久
就升的不多降的很慢
這是這一次主要的劇本
那我們再看一下
那為什麼聯準會要升息
因為我們大家都知道
川普不想要你升息
一直叫你不升級 還叫你上級
那為什麼聯準會你還是要升級
真正的兇手是油價
我們來看8月的CPI
整體的CPI的年增是3.4%
看起來是很高的
這也是聯準會緊張的部分
不過你真的去扣掉食物跟能源的
核心CPI其實只有2.4%
是2021年3月以來的最低
就關鍵在在這裡
很明顯就跟能源有關
汽油年漲了27.4%
那燃料流就年漲了52%
為什麼油這麼貴
因為今年這個大家知道
今年的2月28號
美國跟以色列對伊朗開戰以來
這個荷末斯海峽的航運就嚴重受阻
戰前大概全球有五分之一的石油
要經過這條海峽
那布蘭特原油在戰前
大概在70美元上下浮動
結果今年9月中
一度逼近要到了110美元
那最近就在100到105美元之間的震盪
那核心通膨只有2.4%
已經我們說的是相對
這一段期間以來比較低的
聯準會為什麼還是一定要升呢
那關鍵就是在2021年的教訓
因為當年聯準會說
通膨是暫時性的
就是解封之後的一個短暫需求
結果沒想到那個所謂的暫時性
通膨居然衝到了40年的新高
讓聯準會不得不慌的手腳開始動手
而且還瘋狂的我們前面講的
就是一個暴力升級
那大家後面就一直罵到現在
覺得你可以早點升
為什麼不緩緩地升
要搞到後來很集中地升
升到讓那一次的升級那麼痛苦
所以這一次聯準會就怕到了
就是聯準會這次怕到
就是說油價把大家對通膨的預期拉上去
那就會本來預期通膨變成是真正的通膨
所以一旦預期跟現實脫矛
你很難把他控制回來
所以寧願先動手
先把他壓制住
那講到油呢
我們就一定要提到
本來只有荷木斯海峽的問題
現在又多了胡塞武裝的問題
因為本來沙烏地阿波的策略呢
就是荷木斯海峽呢
走不通
他就靠一個東西向的輸油管
把這個原油本來要從東邊
出口的這個石油呢
輸到沙烏地的西邊
透過鴻海這邊的鹽埠港去出口
這樣就不用走荷莫茲海峽
那這條管線呢
設計容量呢
每天大概是700萬桶
可是到9月開始
情況突然急轉直下
那有幾個狀況
第一個就是胡塞武裝呢
居然南下搶地盤了
因為本來胡塞武裝控制葉門的部分呢
就離這個曼德海峽
這個出口這邊呢
還稍微遠一點
那胡塞武裝南下搶地盤呢
就搶下了這個紅海港口的這個摩卡
那就曼德海峽附近的
這個多座島嶼也被他們控制下來了
那這個曼德海峽在過去和平時期
大概承載全球大約12%的貿易量
那第二個是
胡塞武裝現在對曼德海峽控制力提高之後
對沙烏地的郵輪經過這邊的影響就會更大了
所以
接下來又造成了
沙烏地的實際供給就減少了
那沙烏地8月的雲油產量目前已經降到了每天620萬桶
這是今年的新低
那沙烏地阿美這家國營的石油公司
甚至通知了部分的歐洲客戶說
下個月可能沒有原油可以交貨了
所以高盛就評估了
布蘭特原油漲破120美元的機率已經升高
那也有分析師警告
就是說如果管線繼續停擺個好幾週
油價甚至可能往130美元走
那胡賽武裝的出現呢
他本來把一個海峽的問題
變成是兩個海峽的問題
你就是整個在中東這塊地方
兩個重要出口石油的海峽呢
全部被控制住了
那對通膨對利率來說呢
就是一個很大的尾部風險
我們所謂的尾部風險是什麼呢
就是本來在尾部
通常就是機率發生機率很低
可是如果一旦發生
對現實的衝擊會很大
就是最好不要發生了
但發生的話就會很難處理
所以我用三個情境來推估這個狀況
比較樂觀的情境是
如果管線在8周內修復
那荷莫茲海峽出現了臨時航道
那布蘭特遠有可能就保持在
80到90美元這個區間
這就是大家現在稍微可以安心的區間
當然更好一點是可以回到70美元
那在這種情境下
聯準會的利率趨勢
大概在4%到4.25%這個區間
應該就會停了
甚至到了2027年下半年
有機會討論要不要降息
持平一點的預測
就是現在這種兩個海峽的狀況就僵持住
沒有更壞也沒有更好
那胡賽武裝會持續的打沙烏地阿拉伯船
那油價就會維持在95到110美元這個區間
那利率有可能會因為
兩邊海峽的這個衝突不降溫
就從我們剛才講的就是說
本來高級率是會停在4%到4.25%
就可能再升一碼到4.25%到4.5%
這個區間
然後這個高檔會一直停留到 2027 年的年底
那悲觀一點
就是胡賽真的攻擊了所有的船隻
讓大家都一起死
油價就會衝高到 120 美元以上
那利率呢
我覺得這裡就很難估了
就是它應該可能會上升到 4.25% 到 4.5% 以上更高了
那到底會高到哪裡
就要看這個油價最後衝高到哪裡
這個是屬於很難控制的部分
轉折點什麼時候來
來擬定三個訊號
那因為根據點證圖呢
那官員預測2027年底
這個PCE的通膨
就是個人消費支出這個通膨呢
會回到2.3的附近
那2028年呢
利率才會降到大概3.9%
這個中位數的水準
也就是說
聯準會自己也認為呢
這次的降息呢
要到2027年的很後面
甚至2028年的上半年
那我自己的判斷是這樣
就是說升息的高點呢
大約是落在年底的12月那一次
或是明年初的第一次會議
但是停止升息到開始向降息
中間應該會蠻長的
也就是說大概至少要經過兩個季度
甚至是三個季度是最有可能的
那股價會怎麼樣呢
其實這一波升息前呢
對股價的反應的修正呢
已經完成了
所以這一波在升息的時候呢
緩緩升息的時候
反而股價不會受到影響
但是當市場如果開始大量討論降息的時候
反而是股市大迴盪的風險會提高
因為如果市場大量討論降息
就代表這個降息的急迫性是很高
也代表著這個時候的經濟已經不存在過熱
反而是不是經濟有降溫的風險
所以這時候反而需要趕快用寬鬆貨幣來加持這個市場跟經濟
至於
這種情境什麼時候來投資人注意
訊號一就是第一個當然油價啦
就是布蘭特原油跌回90美元以下而且要站穩這是很重要
那第二個就是勞動市場這是聯準會最重要的指標就是
他升息也主要是因為
覺得失業率很低現在預估只有4.1%就業還很強
所以如果失業率往上走
就代表經濟轉弱了
聯準會對這個緊縮貨幣就會剎車
那第三個當然就是市場的指標
就是十年期的美債
十年期美債呢
如果往下去跌破4.5%
因為十年期美債有個領先性
它往下去
現在是5%以上
如果往下跌破4.5%
代表利率趨勢開始轉變
那這個時候呢
就可能代表聯準會的利率趨勢也會轉變
那我們來看那對債市的影響是什麼
長債呢你就先別急
短債可以先收息
目前10年期美債值率大概是5%
其實看利率是蠻高的
那30年期是在5.3%
那我們先講長天期的值率會這麼高呢
除了因為升息的影響之外呢
還有個重要因素就是美國因為產生赤字大
發債多
所以投資人呢
信心會比較弱一點
就要求更高的期限益酬
也就是說
我要把錢借給你這麼長時間
你當然要多給我一點力氣
多拿一點補償
那我們這邊還要解釋一個觀念就是
債券的存續期間
你可以把它想像成是
債券價格對利率的敏感度
譬如說有一檔長天期美債的ETM
它現在計算出來的
平均存期期限大概是17年
那簡單來看它的意思就是
你用殖利率每上升一個百分點
那價格大概就會跌17%
就是這個一個百分點跟17年這樣的比較
所以存續期的越長
它的價格波動就會越大
那至於我們在債市上面要怎麼反應
第一個當然就是短債就先收起來
因為短天期的美債或短天期美債ETF
它殖利率是跟著這個升息走高
那價格會波動比較小
所以適合當現金短期的停泊區
那常債呢 我覺得原則上是先不要加碼
因為雖然10年在5%以上
利率看起來很有吸引力
不過在這個地域轉折的循環逐漸
加碼的話 你有時候可能會碰到一種情況
因為市場如果悲觀預期說
殖利率會維持這麼高
或是還甚至往上衝的話
那代表債券的價格會存在下跌的壓力
因為利率跟債券價格是反向的
所以我們來談到對股市的影響
臺股這一次對升息的反應
當然是很有意思的
就是升息一開始
股市反而開始上漲
然後因為我們說短期最大利空出盡了
所以我們有機會看到
臺股在這段期間呢
一直到年底呢
拉出這一波主升段的最後一波延伸行情
也就是在年底前呢
有機會再次改寫新高點
甚至就挑戰五萬點
這是有機會的
不過呢
行情應該會用比較波折的方式
就是比較小碎步的方式前進
畢竟現在市場的量呢
是比較小的
那資金的槓桿也受到比較多的管制
不再像是
大概前半年是無限狂奔的資金行情
不過也有一件好事
當然就是這次臺灣押韓維持利率不變
就幫市場留下了這個資金的火筒
讓這個市場的資金不會過度的緊縮
但現實上我們還是要理解一件事
儘管資金面還可以
那市場的信心也還不錯
但是臺股的估值已經不便宜了
這一點是一定要認識的
基本上是
過去基本面不錯可以漲的
或者是有後續想像題材可以漲的
這些股票大概至少都漲過一輪
甚至漲過好幾輪的都有
所以你接下來選股真的會越來越難
那如果真的不擅長選股的人
你用ETF或基金來參與後面的行情
會更安穩一點
以免漲了指數
你自己手上的股票沒漲還下跌
這種情形
到第四季一定會更明顯
比如說真正的會漲的股票
可能數量是越來越少的
而不是那種全面性的大漲
最後總結
總結來看呢
這一次美國升息呢
是被油價逼出來一個防禦性的升息
所以
終點我們前面剛才講
最多大概就是4.25%到4.5%
升的不多
但降的可能會很慢
所以對股市的兩個最大提醒
大家留意
胡賽武裝是最大的不確定性
僵持住可能還好
但是如果升高
衝突升高就很危險
第二個是當市場開始大量討論降息的時候
反而會是這次股市最大的轉折風險的開始
以上就是今天的分享
喜歡我們的節目
歡迎幫我們按贊訂閱分享
以及開啟小鈴鐺
謝謝大家